[Music]
and you say I have written each is that
okay
cuz you know I had said either so I know
I just don't want her to get confused
with a bunch of different eyes coming
from a bunch of different peoples okay
[Music]
last year at the Christmas anyone
mentioned that I did or say anything
that uh oh yeah what if you hear
anything let me know
and oh and have a good happy Halloween
ah yeah got it
GPM I don't know if you saw I got a I
have the corner office it's great that's
great
anyway remember to keep working oh yeah
yeah I can get your email going you said
you have problem logging you know Kay
I'll be I'll be around shortly
[Music]
oh Jesus Christ
you know I've been working here for
[ __ ] 14 years do you know that [ __ ]
has changed your old zeusie a sec yo
fish fish fish [ __ ] hole hey guys so
what you doing after work I think I've
not seen a musical group if you guys
gonna buy it I'll play the cover if you
get it you bros wanna go hey rather Lear
for more dumb shitty videos subscribe to
the GQ channel comm dot org and if you
don't know now you know